[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I'm
taking me go to retro where we're gonna
make George's largest caught up foodies
and I'm taking Caroline to star on spot
where we're gonna try a traditional
hammam bubble treatment come join us on
our adventures on this episode of travel
dares
this is travel there's the show where we
do daring activities all over Europe
empowered by my Mariette Vaughn boy
boundless card
in this episode we're in Tbilisi Georgia
and we're so excited to check out the
cuisine and the culture ready for your
clue girl yes let's get started okay try
not to float away no swimming possibly I
feel it we're going on a like a lazy
river ride or traditional hammam spas
are iconic to this region and they
include a section where you are covered
in bubbles Caroline and I have tried
beauty treatments from all over the
world so I know she's gonna love this
one reach this hand down down down and
scoop are you stupid
take off your blindfold
oh my god oh my god
Oh instantly so much it feels so warm in
here
I feel like a queen all the eggs are her
right away bad idea her mom is an
ancient ritual Ottomans brought their
own birthing tradition to Constantinople
in 15th century hama meaning is the
spreader of warmth
it's a rejuvenating procedure living
you're feeling refreshed inside and out
[Music]
come on positive effects on different
party functions physical and emotional
detox clean skin pores of impurities and
spots the dead skin pain relief mask or
relaxation reliefs and stresses was the
immune system and giving you
unforgettable feeling my skin feels
silky smooth
every time I rub in the bubbles would
just feel softer and softer
I definitely think out of all the songs
I've ever been to this one is my
favorite Mika I have a little surprise
for you
oh it's a soggy this boat won't float
blind money once we get these alive
[Music]
I don't know I don't know any non
floating boats every boat that I've met
floats
Koch opera is an iconic Georgian dish
consisting of eggs cheese and bread
retro is known to make one of the
largest hot chocolate in the world and
chef Jia is going to teach us how to
make it and they'll stop here oh okay
perfect
okay all right know what this is I don't
know what a peace treaty like a cheesy
pastry because today we're learning how
to make okay Georgian cheeseburger so
without making category yeah yeah yeah
Nico I do have a surprise for you we're
not just making watch out booty we're
making an over five but watch out booty
Nick are you ready to do this yes that's
something our body eats it
no vodka Masuda ton patera winner Roger
balls work for most appearances on there
that's what Roger bones koala potential
Michels helibase modular words well
establish only gradually Raja Bhoj
equalities Rhonda
it's so creamy and delicious and rich
because of all that okay we did it
[Applause]
airline that was so delicious no out of
all the places we've traveled to Georgia
is so unique I know I love staying in
Tbilisi it has such a rich history like
this hotel was constructed in 1910 and
it's the first European Standard Hotel
in Tbilisi Caroline let's talk below I
think you did a really good job of
staying really positive and relaxed
throughout the whole process even when
your skin was being scrub you did a
really good job so I'll give you five
stars yes I loved it I had such an
amazing time and my skin feels so so
making that giant hot shot booty
requires a lot of skill and a lot of
speed and I'm still glad you didn't drop
it when we're taking it to the oven
thought we were a little slow during the
preparation process especially the eggs
that was a little frantic so for that
I'm giving you a four point five out of
five four point five I guess that's fair
that's fair
yeah it was still so delicious yeah
Georgia was amazing but now we're about
to meet a jade here I'm super excited
for that AJ we're coming
[Music]